[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat si vous nous rejoignez ce matin
nous vous proposons de suivre l'audition
du général lecointe c'est le chef d'état
major des armées
il est auditionné ce matin par la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat dans le cadre du budget 2021 je
vous propose de regarder ces échanges et
on se retrouve après savoir quels sont
les sentiments qui ont animé la junte
malienne actuellement au pouvoir
pour réaliser cette opération et nous
avons été extrêmement choqués de voir
comment ces terroristes ont été fêtés
par un dea de leurs dirigeants qui est
parmi les plus recherchées par notre
pays et tout ceci je tenais à vous le
dire car c'est un sentiment qui est
partagé à travers l'ensemble des groupes
de notre commission alors en général
bien sûr je reviens à l'essentiel de
cette audition qui concerne les
questions budgétaires et qui va
permettre à mes collègues de vous
interroger
je veux simplement faire état pour
lancer le débat de deux préoccupations
qui sont fortes
bien sûr 2021 c'est une année que nous
attendions et que nous pourrions aussi
redoutés puisqu'il s'agit de l'année de
la re de l'actualisation de la loi de
programmation militaire
la commission s'y préparer elle a d'ores
et déjà commencé sous le précédent
mandat
un certain nombre d'investigations et si
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de réelle
inquiétude
nous voudrions être sûr que cette
actualisation de la lpm d'une part sur
le plan purement formelle prennent la
forme d'une loi car ce qu'une loi pose
une loi doit une autre loi doit pouvoir
le modifier
est ce que c'est bien du reste
intentions du gouvernement c'est moins
vous qu'au gouvernement que nous avons
posé cette question mais est-ce que vous
avez bien ce sentiment et je pense que
vous souvenez combien le parlement et
singulièrement le sénat a permis de
solidifier cet engagement qui permet de
de remettre à niveau nos forces armées
qui en aviez qui en avait tant besoin
et puis bien sûr à travers
cet exercice budgétaire 2021 nous
attendons un certain nombre d'arbitrages
sur des grands sujets le porte avions de
nouvelle génération bien sûr qui a fait
l'objet d'un premier rapport cette année
qui vous a été remis il ya bien sûr pour
nos forces sous marines
le questionnement autour de l'avenir du
sous marin nucléaire d'attaqué la perle
quand va-t-on véritablement savoir quel
non seulement si ce sous marin peut
faire l'objet de réparations mais
quelles conséquences pour l'ensemble des
forces sous-marines cet accident peut
avoir nous avons bien sûr toujours dans
ses arbitrages de sujets importants des
questionnements sur la commande des
rafale supplémentaires à la suite du
contrat grecque
si l'on se réjouit de voir à travers la
mise à disposition d'un certain nombre
d'appareils d'occasion et la vente de
six rafale nov
une brique supplémentaire à cette europe
de la défense que nous souhaitons bien
évidemment il convient que ce ne soit
pas au détriment de nos forces aériennes
nous serons demain sur la base d'evreux
avec un certain nombre de collègues donc
on voulait avoir un petit peu votre
sentiment sur cette affaire est ce que
vous pensez du reste que nos industriels
pourront réellement augmenter les
cadences de production pour encore une
fois rattraper au plus vite ce départ
des rafales qui pour une part vont être
mis à disposition de la grèce des l'été
21 voilà quelques questions et puis
l'ensemble du cadrage budgétaire que
vous souhaiterez faire dans une
présentation pour lequel je vais vous
donner dans un instant la parole et puis
après nous aurons comme d'habitude non
pas de la part ne rapportera car ils
seront nommés la semaine prochaine mais
de la part des collègues qui le
souhaitent soit en présentiel soit par
vidéo
nous aurons quelques questions à vous
poser en général vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup a dit quand je veux tout
d'abord félicitations à vous même
supplée dans l'élection et les puits au
nouveau nouveau une attaque il
rejoindrait de cette commission qui est
important en nous qui est essentiel
c'est bien juste titre du parlement
savait que les arbitres sont très
attachés à ce que des parlementaires
si on la coupe claire possible de l'état
de reconstruction de notre armée sont la
cible de ces engagements il est très
important pour nous de nous sentir
soutenus par des sociétés françaises
il m'a dit ma nation et donc en nous
c'est extrêmement important comme ça
rendez vous délirez était
particulièrement important à chaque fois
j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à échanger
avec les sénateurs comme avec les
députés de langage et devenir le
contrôle libye n'a que j'ai prévu en
2009 et d'entamer notre chance
aujourd'hui je voudrais tout de suite
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit
monsieur le président à propos de la
libération de la libération de
prisonniers qui étaient détenus dans les
prisons maliennes et de échange de sa
dernière la libération qui a été obtenue
en partie mon âge je soutiens un certain
nombre de choses à ce sujet là tout
d'abord pour que les choses reviennent
au mais l'adversaire qui est le nôtre
n'est pas un groupe armé comme un autre
qui serait un groupe armé d'opposition
au régime ben ali
s'agit bien d'un d'une organisation
terroriste internationale et il s'agit
pour la partie de cette organisation qui
sévit au mali entre autres terroristes
et de groupes terroristes qui ont fait
allégeance à al qaïda et dont l'objectif
est un objectif qui contrevient
directement à la sécurité des français à
l'étranger et son territoire national et
un groupe terroriste qui paraît ya des
modes d'action qui sont très clairement
dès votre action terroriste
donc on ne peut absolument pas imaginer
que ce groupe terroriste puisse être
comparée ou désignés comme un groupe
armé d'opposition au régime malien
de la même façon on ne peut pas appeler
ces personnes des militaires et imaginer
que philippe attey de comparer aux
militaires français 1416 aux soldats
d'une armée régulière qui se battent
dans l'aspect niveau international dans
le respect du droit de la guerre
en maîtrisant leur violence et qu'il est
en permanence au tas de la mission
qu'ils ont reçue par une éthique
particulièrement exigeante et donc en
aucun cas on peut comparer ses soldats
et la façon dont ils remplissent
admirablement leur mission à
comportement de ces coupes armés
terroristes auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés enfin les flamands des
soldats français n'aurait jamais l'idée
qu'il ya la libération de prisonniers
ans tu es un ennemi et faire des otages
aux populations civiles
voilà je tire cela propos qui ont été
tenus
vraiment la libération de valentin qui
me semble-t-il risque de fausser
l'appréciation qu'on va d'avoir de la
situation au mali l'engagement de
l'armée française engagement qui reste
aujourd'hui que jamais est clair et et
guidée par la volonté
d'apatrides terroristes de garantir la
sécurité des français seraient opposés
au régime
je tenais à dire soyez assurés que ce
message je leur dirai à mes soldats la
ministre ne réduira également et qui
doit être très clair l'ensemble des
familles qui ont perdu des leurs dans
les combats que nous menons au mali
depuis des années il peut être très
calme
sa famille ne dévions pas de lui qu à
notre combat reste le même et il est
tout aussi légitime qu'il n'était en
particulier en ce qui concerne cette
libération d'otages confiant que la
france n'a en rien été impliqué dans ces
négociations d'aucune sorte avec ce
groupe terroriste que nous continuerons
à combattre avec la dernière
détermination voilà ce que je souhaitais
en préambule sur ce sujet qui me tient à
coeur du président comme je le sais qui
c'est qu'il vous tient à coeur de la
sphère qui nous réunit aujourd'hui qui
est qui et sorte de point d'étape nous
conversion d'exécution de la nuitée 2020
dans votre programmation militaire
et puis le projet de loi de finances
2011 et 1 je voudrais développer un
certain nombre d'éléments d'abord
remplir notre président
depuis l'année en février dernier à
l'école de gain en réaffirmant sa
volonté de doter la france d'un outil de
défense complet moderne puissant
équilibré mise en oeuvre par des armes
et réactive et des tournées vers
l'avenir et il a confirmé donc à cette
occasion que cet objectif sar est
atteint au prix d'un effort budgétaire
inédite ce qui est vrai
c'était fort au budget d'haïti c'est la
loi de programmation est aujourd'hui
pour la troisième annuité de cette loi
de programmation
nous observons une confirmation de la
volonté présidentielle
avec un objectif qui n'a pas changé et
qui pour moi chef d'état major des
armées est un objectif opérationnel
stratégique qui est de disposer à
l'horizon 2030
au terme d'une deuxième programmation
d'un modèle d'armée complète qui
permettra de garantir le maintien de la
crédibilité de dissuasion qui permettra
également de faire face à notre ambition
personnelle du référence qui reste la
capacité à engager l'armée française à
la fois la situation nationale de
référence et dans une hypothèse qui est
dimensionné et dimensionnant pour notre
modèle d'armée et qui fait d'ailleurs de
nous amener à mêler mon entraînement
important en europe et dans le monde
occidental
alors pour développer mon propos je vais
évoquer d'abord rapidement les
engagements non un point précis sur la
situation vers sionnel de tuto pour
essayer d'illustrer les moyens et qui
sont engagés aujourd'hui dans ses
engagements qui permettent d'avoir
ensuite meilleure compréhension de
d'efforts et la nécessité de l'effort
qui est fourni dans cette programmation
qui se traduit notamment par des
livraisons d'équipements qu'on doit
ensuite être capable de rapporter que
même équipement engagé à ne pas subir
qu'ensuite je ferai un bilan provisoire
de la gestion de be back
et puis je vous dis elle regarde donc
quels sont les engagements de poupées
anciennes deux armées en 2001 qu'est-ce
qu'ils acquittent en termes d'engagement
des capacités militaires
tout d'abord je voudrais dire que le
niveau d'engagement mais reste élevé
depuis deux armées plusieurs années mais
cette année en particulier du serge qui
étaient décidées par le président de la
république et qui a débuté à partir de
la fin du mois de janvier dernier
ce niveau ce niveau d'engagement
encore atteint des sommets sur le point
des effectifs depuis le début de l'année
c'est un peu plus de 7800 tonnes qui
sont engagés chaque jour et sur le
territoire national c'est 12500 qui sont
en situation opérationnelle en temps le
débat national d'urgence depuis le 1er
janvier dernier
au delà des effectifs qui sont
significatifs je pense qu'il est utile
de les compliquer a quelques chiffres
qui permettent d'illustrer de ce qu'est
besoins en équipements en opérations
extérieures pour la mettre en opération
marque a aujourd'hui plus de 500
véhicules blindés lourds et légers et
plus de 400 véhicules logistiques dit
qu'elle ne transparaît qui mène le
dépannage des moyennes manutention
notamment pour les véhicules blindés a
publié aujourd'hui ses 110 femmes ultima
qui sont déployés sur le théâtre pour un
parc total 290 à minima et pourra pas
opérationnelle de 200 victimes a donc
vous le voyez c'est aujourd'hui plus de
plus de 50% de nova multiman
opérationnels qui sont déployés en
opérations extérieures
vous voyez donc il y gère viendrait
l'importance qu'il ya à un remplacement
de ses équipements dans le cadre de sa
programmation
puisqu'il s'agit bien d'un emploi
courant des forces dans ces équipements
et avec la nécessité également d'un
niveau de performance de cet équipement
qui garantisse à la fois l'efficacité de
nos armées et la protection de soldats
pour la marine
l'opération est finie a vu l'engagement
des régates de lutte anti-sous-marine
latouche tréville le récemment décidé de
ré engager la france dans la nation
il ya quelques semaines je je je
souligne au passage que cet effectif en
1990 et que sera remplacé dans ses
fonctions de lutte anti-sous-marine par
la frégate
payet courbet rénové qui part bientôt en
service qui permettra d'attendre
l'arrivée des cinq premières frégates de
défense et d'intervention dans la
commande est prévue en 2020 maintenant
il est prévu qu'en 2021 des chiffres
d'engagement de certaines capacités
phare de même 3 et que les trois parties
et les six régates mission totaliseront
chacun d'ici la fin de l'année en
moyenne plus de 130 jours de mer
ces chiffres sont à rapprocher de la
norme qui a été définie par notre
programmation qui est de 110 jours de
même par bâtiment bien là poids de la
pression avec évidemment au delà de
notre gaz extérieur les opérations qui
ont été conduites cette année qui était
par définition a prévu l'opération
résilience qui va mener à engager des
moyens le aux antilles les moyens
maritimes aux antilles en corse ou à la
réunion et l'opération amitié qui a
engagé nos moyens maritimes
les prennent pour la pâte sont
régulièrement engagés en atlantique nord
en littérale et dans le détroit d'ormuz
pour l'occasion un génome vous y serez
enfin ce lien entre notre engagement
visionnaire et la réalisation des
capacités qui sont nécessaires d'armé et
qui font l'objet de la programmation
était en cours je le souhaitais vos
pieds l'armée de l'air et de l'espace et
le cas particulier du trône river
aujourd'hui nous possédons trois
systèmes de systèmes sont déployés à
niamey dans le cadre de l'opération
marcal et 1 et mises en oeuvre en
métropole pour la préparation
rationnelle et donc la livraison d'un
quatrième système nous permettra à des
projections de cette capacité à 50%
c'est décidemment urgence et nécessité
absolue de respecter le cadencement des
ducs la zone tel qu'il est prévu par la
programmation
alors quel peut être le bilan provisoire
à l'exécution la loi de finances de
ligue 1 avec évidemment une difficulté
qui a été la crise peu vide qui n'a pas
été sans impact sur l'exécution
budgétaire 2001 je souhaite tout d'abord
a relevé que la mpm a été en réalité un
véritable ressort de sortie de crise les
outils de rebond dans cette crise but
vide
c'est en effet en s'appuyant sur la sbm
que nous avons pu en liaison avec la dg
à identifier en amont le potentiel non
il y reprendre des latins de confinement
la gestion de 1 an précédent lancement
d'opérations en substitution des
annulations qui avait tété qui avaient
été rencontrés à ce stade d'évaluation
en victoire des effets de la crise et de
2,1 milliards cent de moindres commandes
qui sont compensées par 301 millions la
population de mesures nouvelles à
hauteur de 800 millions d'euros
l'intégralité des crédits non consommés
a été déployée au profit d'un plan
rebond qui comprend principalement des
crédits qui sont destinés au soutien de
la filière aéronautique savez qui se
traduit par des commandes anticipées
parenté andrier de la langue ou la masse
monétaire quand d'avion de drones
militaires ce qui apporte un soutien
concret et veiller à la préservation de
l'emploi en particulier dans les pme de
la filière lait qui permet par ailleurs
de tout en ayant des effets de
substitution de conserver des objectifs
de l'est pas en capacité un logo
d'albums en la matière aujourd'hui on
estime que tout ce qu'on retombe et en
transit mais sur nos pas et sur t&d des
commandes livraisons que nous
anticipions une souhaitions c'est pas
programmation des deux sans doute
halabi 21 au plus tard à la relayant
d'une part anticipé certaines de ces
commandes est décalé d'autres les
commandes aujourd'hui anticiper
trois avions de transport c-130 qui vont
être transformés à terre en mrct avec de
livraison dès le début 1
et puis un avion léger de surveillance
et de renseignement avec une application
et enfin des drones de surveillance
navale aussi sur le plan des effectifs
nous avons pu aussi limiter les effets
de la crise par une reprise très
dynamique de recrutement de la bête
estime ainsi pierre à réaliser son plan
de recrutement à 90% en dépit des
contraintes copie d'ici la fin de
l'année
par ailleurs un ralentissement des
sorties et des départs permettent permet
d'envisager la teinte des slips
d'effectifs pour la fin de l'exercice
avec le départ aujourd'hui qui sont
inférieurs de l'ordre de 2000 aux
prévisions qui avait été fait ce qui
permet de compenser des les quelques
retards de recrutement
et malgré tout qu'ils sont localement de
la même hauteur en train de l'exécution
de m
si tu as le des essentiels soutiennent
l'économie et des territoires des armées
et l'entretien en région représente un
budget de fonctionnement de 3 euros la
plupart des marchés soutient le lait de
marché qui sont passés localement avec
les petites entreprises pour l'armée de
l'air n'est ce pas une livraison
d'aéronefs ont été conformes avec
l'a400m atlas qui permet à la flotte de
passer à 17 appareils un avion
ravitailleurs multirôles mrtt phoenix
qui permet de faire passer la faute à
trois appareils ainsi 130j qui permet de
faire passer d'un ford à quatre
appareils qui permet d'ores et déjà
d'atteindre l'objectif 2025
ça nous offre évidemment une capacité
très améliorée d'accueil aux opérations
avec un transport stratégique et
tactique bien ravitaillement en vol qui
sont en cours de restauration et qui
vous le savez sont des capacités très
sollicité en particulier au sahel
aujourd'hui mais également de rappeler
et rappeler l'autre jour les envies que
lors de deux opérations
quels qu'ils soient en particulier lors
de l'opération hamilton qui avait
suscité un nombre des ravitailleurs
extrêmement important l'armée de terre
avoir 98 sont livrés d'ici la fin
d'année
certains commande initiale et du clan
des maisons initial envoyé à 128,9 ans
je pense que toi mais nous avons quand
même 90 enfants qui ont été livrés cette
année pour la marine dont un atlantic 2
rénové qui a déjà été dit est un site
avec sa seule exigence complexification
de la lutte anti sous marine et en
termes de cohérence générale de notre
modèle
200 missiles de moyenne portée qui ont
été commandés un lieu qui permettra de
disposer de stocks suffisants pour les
opérations ou en baisse également pour
garantir la réactivité nos armées en cas
de nouvelle intervention
alors quel est le cinéma vision
aujourd'hui du chef d'état-major sur sur
le plf 2021 bien s'appelle monsieur qui
confirme l'ambition qui a été ratée par
avec eux un budget de la défense qui est
passé depuis 2010 est de 32,2 milliards
de milliards d'euros dominateur c'est à
dire une évolution conforme à l'avis de
la vigne d'évolution de la loi de
programmation et qui est objectivement
un effort manifeste commence on dansait
déjà sentir les trains des effets dans
les sens je mesure bien l'exigence le
qui pèsent sur les armes et à cet effort
qui est objectivement sans précédent
pour parler de ce pdf 2020 tiens je vais
d'abord vous évoquez ce qu'il comporte
ce qui n'en portent en matière de
renouvellement des capacités militaires
de nos armées ensuite ce qu'il permet en
matière de préparation de l'avenir et en
fait je n'oublie pas enfin je aussi en
matière de matière de danse de loi de
programmation militaire à hauteur
d'homme qui était que nous nous étions
collectivement fixé qui était très
important et que je sais et les
parlementaires sont particulièrement
attentifs à tous d'avoir le
renouvellement de capacités
opérationnelles se paie selon deux axes
la modernisation d'une part la
réparation et la modernisation
c'est une relation par l'emplacement des
capacités emplacement qui par ailleurs
permet en même temps l'organisation qui
se bat depuis six ans et technologique
de défense performante
nous disposons au plan national permet
aujourd'hui de nos armées par
remplacement d'équipements qui
garantissent tu peux arrêter
opérationnelle des exigences de
protection de nos âmes et enfin
aujourd'hui certaines capacités arrives
tu à obsolescence notamment aux
véhicules de l'avant blindé d'évacuation
certains avec un niveau de protection
qui est insuffisant ou alors qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui en dehors de toute
performance acceptable et dont le
remplacement était mutins dans le cadre
de la marine par exemple nous sommes
aujourd'hui contraints de recourir à la
mise en place par contrat de location
pour éviter la rupture capacités en
retrait des alouettes
arrivé de lille interrogée
je note que 30 hélicoptères mais les
jets sont recommandés en 2021 profit des
trois armées
on les bat sanitaire déjà déployé 14h au
standard en trio de stars yens nous
avons commandé les instants d'art en
trio des de 30 actuellement
ces solutions ne vise qu'à tenir le
temps de voir évacuations sanitaires
je vais éviter l'effet liste à la
prévert de vous détailler l'ensemble je
vais cependant relevé quelques
livraisons particulièrement
emblématiques qui permettent d'illustrer
mon propos tout d'abord nous avons cette
année la qualifiant de l'actif de
l'admission en 2021 en service actif du
sous marin nucléaire d'attaqué qui est
le premier de sa vie pour ma part dans
la cible est de six bâtiments quand vous
savez je suis fera un remplaçant de
nouvelles capacités et donc tout en
maintenant le nombre de capacités sous
marine à niveau ce qui est indispensable
polarisation
optionnel il offrira supériorité
opérationnelle notamment en matière de
mise en oeuvre de forces spéciales en
matière de capacité de vram de la mère
de lui de la mer la mise en forme de
missiles de croisière la balle mieux et
il apportera une supériorité gamme en
matière de discrétion acoustique qui va
être particulièrement utile et qui va
maintenir la capacité sous marine
française
au premier niveau mondial nous avons
également pour l'heure des terres la
poursuite de livraison de sport pions
avec eux 157 griffon qui vient de
remplacer de l'étude d'adp les sapins
aujourd'hui des années 80
notre objectif est la projection d'un
cocon tactique scorpions ici la fin de
l'année prochaine au sahel avec une
trentaine de griffon qui remplaceront
autant de bab dévoyé et qui apporteront
au delà d'une protection et d'une
mobilité supérieure à lausanne a les
capacités de numérisation qui devraient
permettre de commencer à évoluer
considérablement la manoeuvre la
manoeuvre d'infanterie nous allons
également recevoir des avoirs qui est
équipé d'un canon 40 ont remplacés et
ont commencé à remplacer une partie du
prêt 6 1 pc vieillissants et qui arrive
aujourd'hui aux couleurs des options et
enfin nous avons la livraison de trois
unités ce qui permettra de poursuivre la
rationalisation de la capacité de
transport stratégique et ravitaillement
en vol et de conforter les contraintes
nationales en particulier les
contraction liée à la mise en oeuvre de
la dissuasion nucléaire ici 21 nous
disposerons d'un parc de six engins et
pour ainsi poursuivre le retrait de
services équipements anciens notamment
de kc-135 dans la livraison a été fait à
l'époque du général de gaulle qui est un
massif trafic de la nécessité de
poursuivre cette démarche leur
emplacement
qui permet de réparer le modèle alors
autant du renouvellement que je viens
d'évoquer il ya le deuxième axe qui va
de la réparation s'agit là de combler
les ruptures ou les réductions capacités
qui limite considérablement de capaci
d'action qui si on ne s'attaque à ce
sujet là on perd la possibilité d'
atteinte de l'ambition conserver un
modèle d'armée complet les bacs d'une
capacité à combler je voudrais citer en
est ici la vie passant de 14,2 gage de
mitterrand avec nadia nick moderniser si
fier qui permettra d'améliorer les
capacités d'un puits cheveux et
bombardements si on revient avec la
livraison du ragga lafayette rénové qui
va être équipé d'un sonar de coque et de
capacités de détection sous marine une
région pas qui permet de restaurer la
capacité de casse régates de premier
rang en attendant l'arrivée des gasy
défense et d'invention pour ce qui
concerne la restauration d'incohérences
nous allons en 2021 recevoir 12
milliards
nous allons recevoir aussi 150 paires de
jumelles remix jumelles de vision
nocturne km à 6,2 de renouveler cet
équipement 7e peut paraître de moindre
importance et qui en réalité sont
essentielles 9,6 à la cohérence
engagement à la complétude de nos
capacités du combat lee qui compte
également de façon importante le moral
nous nous sommes avons également une
restauration de la cohérence par la
livraison d'un lot de missiles de
croisière naval pour le sénat barracuda
et de missiles aster 30 la fremm de
défense aérienne comment également le
lit maison de 440 à de s habiller de 14
hors des six nations
alios qui permettront d'améliorer les
capacités
particulier dans le domaine de l'appui
aérien rapproché mais aussi s'agit de
veiller à la cohérence d'un modèle qui
ne passe pas seulement par les
plateformes principales mais qui passe
par ambitionnait d'accompagnement qui
sont indispensables en réalité à
l'emploi opérationnel de ces équipements
et puis enfin nous avons également le
souci de préserver les formes réparation
de leur montrer savait que au même titre
que la livraison de capacité c'est ce
maintien de la préparation
opérationnelle à bon niveau
si tu t'y la réparation aux capacités
j'observe que on années 2020 le niveau
seront 1 en dépit d'un impact fort de la
la qu'est-ce que vides
l'armée de terre devrait ainsi atteindre
un niveau de trace en 18 jours en
version personnelle parole si l'année
avec une cible initiale 80 jours il ya
un objectif final pour 2025 et de 90
jours par an pour les pilotes de l'armée
pour les pilotes de chasse de l'armée de
l'air a atteint 151 heures de vol par
pilote entre les 164 cas lui un objectif
de 180 heures de vol et je l'évoqué tout
à l'heure où la marine nationale en 2013
au dessus en préparation personnelle
avec les bâtiments de combat de la
marine nationale sont deux jours demain
contre un objectif qui est fixé à 80
avec l'objectif de l'asm 2025 et 200
jours de mes parents ces objectifs sont
ambitieux je voulais dit on à cet effort
son reste ambitieux sur les crocs de
je pense que nous atteindrons cet
objectif ils continueront malgré malgré
des soubresauts de la crise en débit
continueront à savoir réalité
non seulement atteint deux objectifs
opérationnels dans nos engagements
extérieurs mais aussi à la présentation
de la ville d'eauze en équivalence
enfin il ya le domaine de la préparation
de la ville qui est complémentaire de
cette restauration capacité nouvellement
réparation cette préparation de l'avenir
essentiel nous oriente sur ce que seront
les armes et en 2040 la loi
programmation actuelle n'est pas une
armée n'est pas une programmation qui va
d'emblée se traduire par des livraisons
capacités et d'avenir mais elle doit
danser déjà préparer le lancement
je pense évidemment aux grands
programmes structurés en particulier
programme on a un objet céleste
le drone mâle européens savaient que
nous avons l'intention de structurer la
coopération internationale autour de ces
grands projets de fédérer des
partenaires autour de la france et de
créer autour de ces grands projets de
l'étape suivante et européennes sur ce
chemin nous avons au delà de ces grands
projets structurants de atik être
anticipées dont la livraison est plus
urgente qu'initialement anticipé je
pense en particulier au domaine
nationale de médecine air donc il faut
dès aujourd'hui investir pour développer
nos capacités opérationnelles ne s'agit
pas là de combler dès votre capacité
moyen d'une informatique défensive et
offensive
ainsi le g6 baer sera porté à 201
millions d'euros
c'est également le cadre de l'espace
avec la budgétisant à 4 millions d'euros
avec le lancement de la construction des
infrastructures du camp de l'espace
auquel par ailleurs nous souhaitons
pouvoir ajouter un centre d'excellence
de l'otan
peut-on colocalisé avec un centre c'est
également la livraison de deux
satellites d'observations de l'éducation
et une première capacité des goudes
spatiale avec le système crs avec trois
satellites
enfin je note de 2021 la première année
du cadre financier pluriannuel pour le
fonds européen de défense qui je le
rappel s'élève à 700 milliards d'euros à
7 milliards d'euros avec l'élaboration
d'un programme de travail et développer
des projets capacités en coopération
cette préparation de l'avenir c'est
également l'innovation de défense est
une organisation et méthode nouvelle
l'agent citation de france l'objectif
c'est bien d'accélérer le développement
des ports anp d'innovation et de le
conserver en 2021 les mois associée à
cette ambition c'est de loin le système
décentralisé réseaux d'innovation des
centres à des actions de proximité passe
par des investissements va partout
dieu sur le maintien en conditions
opérationnelles le budget de l'ue
confirme d'efforts importants des
crédits d'entretien avait du matériel
il s'agit là d' améliorer nos taux de
disponibilité et de régénérer le
matériel et de remonter l'activité la
main d'henry d'évoquer un instant qu'ils
sont prévues par l'accord national des
crédits de pm commenteront d'un milliard
et demi d'euros en autorisations
d'engagement
il nous permettra en particulier de
poursuivre la titrisation des des
contrariétés entamés par l'allemagne
les équipements de proximité sont
importants financée aux 146 mais
également aux 178
il profite directement à deux soldats et
à l'amélioration des conditions
d'exercice du métier
je note en particulier pour que pour
l'année à venir
la livraison de deux gilets pare balles
qu'on appelle une structure modulaire
balistique qui est important de
garanties de sécurité
clairement qu'ils bénéficient qui permet
aux soldats de retrouver améliorée et
très grande modularité
un programme qui bénéficie sur la durée
d'un vote dont la masse ionique la
vacance financier 240 millions d'euros
l'acquisition de plus de 200 9102
structure modulaire balistique
à ce jour treize mille deux cents de ces
structures de la bastille qu'on était
irène trier les trois qui est issu du
programme pèlerins qui est un pays qui
marque un saut qualitatif et protection
renforcée entre risques de feu et puis
une meilleure résistance de nous plier
misant à son profit en 2009 il encourt
de prendre les généraliser
progressivement 4 avec le sivu qui vend
des millions quatre cent huit rallyes
pour un coût de près de 200 millions
d'euros à ce jour
400000 plus 400 élus cré y ont été
livrés depuis début de l'opération dit m
et puis vous aimez quinze type pistolet
semi automatique
en ce qui concerne les infrastructures
le budget qu'il était mon filtre à
remédier à nos services dans ce domaine
très sensible augmente plus 55 millions
d'euros en autorisations d'engagement et
70 millions d'euros en équipements
ça va nous permettre d'améliorer
progressivement les conditions de
travail et d'accueil dans les régimes en
or est basée à vienne avec le par
ailleurs un effort bénéficiant des
logements qui se poursuit également en
2021 avec 256 millions d'euros
d'autorisations d'engagement et 95
millions d'euros de crédits avant de
conclure je voudrais d'évoquer quelques
points d'attention
le premier c c'est le cas souvent qui au
départ est uniquement à des questions
statut rémunération même si c'était son
statut et de la migration sont
importantes
je vais y revenir en ce qui concerne la
rémunération admire année de lancement
de la nouvelle politique de rémunération
2008 par des proportions qu nous étions
tous plus importante mais le sedif qui
est atteint l'objectif gamme mandat avec
38 premiers millions d'euros qui sont
prévues au profit de la nouvelle
indemnité de mobilité géographique
c'est une revalorisation bossuet mais
elle est indispensable le souci étant
que la fidélisation deux ans par
ailleurs attentifs poursuivre l'examen
de l'ensemble de cette
[Musique]
ps mes respects des glaciers de gestion
besoins restent un sujet de beaucoup de
bons général pardonnez moi de vous était
donné comme mission essentielle en
général je ne sais pas si vous
m'entendez mais la liaison est très
mauvaise et votre intervention est
malheureusement h et si vos
collaborateurs et techniciens pouvait
remédier à ce problème parce que on a du
mal à suivre votre propos est l'image
tant l'image que le son sont un peu
déficient
il va falloir un satellite entre le
sénat et la place balard
est ce que est ce que vous nous entendre
est ce que vous nous entendez mon
général si si on vous voit de manière
assez floue mais surtout votre propos
est haché donc la liaison n'est pas très
très bonne c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
alors très bien si on vit ça pendant
deux ans
j'observe que du reste parfois les
communications avec washington ou pékin
sont bien meilleures qu'avec le
l'arrondissement d'à côté
voilà vous avez pu suivre l'audition du
général lecointe chef d'état-major des
armées il était donc auditionné par les
membres de la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat dans le cadre du
budget 2021 c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez retrouver toute
l'actualité parlementaire sur notre site
internet publie senat.fr et je vous
souhaite une excellente journée à tous
[Musique]